[Music]
the nazis dream of a thousand year reich
but in truth they are already dead
they've all machine shattered stalingrad
but the evil regime staggers on
desperate to snatch victory from the
jaws of defeat the special battalion of
ss troops scoured the globe for a
supernatural means to win the war
they were led by the most dangerous man
i ever met
over
[Music]
experts from across iraq archaeologists
explorers historians and authorities on
the account like myself they were forced
to help them loot sacred antiquities but
none of the relics we found gave von
lists the power he craved
then something happened in poland and
changed everything
another nazi attempt to alter the course
of divorce somehow weakens a barrier
between this world and the next
unleashing the forces of darkness
many miles away five of our artifacts
suddenly
awakened
[Music]
ancient spirits demons if you will
beckon from these otherworldly relics
whispering a promise of power
[Applause]
and of course
for list acceptance
[Music]
he now has the power to raise the dead
and they plan to take back every single
nuts he's lost
all the troops he will ever require life
throws him into the mess graves of the
eastern front
to stop his unholy army
they must fight their eyes
for the thousand
consume us all
yeah boy